hi Matt here before we get started I
know thinkfast talk smart listeners love
to learn and hone their communication
and Leadership skills here's a fantastic
opportunity for you Stanford Graduate
School of Business offers over 50
Executive Education programs in person
and online designed for leaders of all
experience levels and career interests
unlock your leadership potential and go
to grow. stanford.edu
SL learn to find the program for
you hi Matt here we have a special treat
for you today I am excited to introduce
you to the latest Stamford GSB podcast
if then if you like think fast talk
smart then please consider if then each
episode has a Stanford GSB faculty
member talking about their area of
research and its realworld application
take a listen to this episode featuring
my colleague friend and past think fast
talks smart guest Jonathan lvav after
learning from Jonathan on if then please
check out think fast talks smart
episodes 88 and 94 to hear more from
Jonathan please enjoy if then and be
sure to subscribe and add it to your
playlist I already
have if we want to generate better
ideas then we need to get people back to
the office
first of all the Rhythm thing right will
Tracy was an executive producer on the
HBO series succession a co-writer of the
film the menu and was a staff writer for
Last Week Tonight with John Oliver
during his career he's been in a lot of
writers rooms when you're with a group
of writers physically around a table in
a room there's a sense of ideas building
on each other following directly on the
heels of somebody's idea maybe even in a
way that feels not rude but
collaborative almost jumping on top of
someone's sentence and so it's almost
like you are crafting that idea together
at the same
time when writing a season of a
television show creators can spend up to
three or four months in a writer's room
voling ideas talking about characters in
different situations it is a highly
creative and collaborative environment
in his many years as a writer will has
never tried to do that kind of
collaboration
virtually with zoom there's always this
kind of forced good manners where you
have to wait for someone to come to a
complete end of their statement and then
there's a lag because people are also
waiting for did that go through is there
a time lag between anyone here so
someone finishes their sentences and
then there's like a 4 second
Gap and then someone starts to speak
again and that just doesn't have the
Rhythm and dynamism of real conversation
it doesn't feel like a real conversation
it feels like people are making a
prepared statement then there's a wait
and then there's another prepared
statement and I don't know how it works
for other businesses I think for writing
that is not
great will sees the value of virtual
meetings for some gatherings in fact
this conversation with Will was done on
Zoom but he doesn't think this
technology is well suited for writers in
a collaborative setting I also have a
feeling just knowing how writers are and
how distracted they are and how they
like to procrastinate and distract
themselves I always am suspecting that
somebody is at least two or three people
on the zoom screen are looking at their
email or looking at another window on
their laptop and finding a way to avoid
writing and and confronting something
head on because they think well these
other people are talking and no one
knows what I'm really doing right now
and you can't do that in the writer's
room you're right there on stage
basically everyone has to be focused on
the task you avoid that problem
completely you need the Grist of
everyday life for a writer's room you
need to talk about what you had for
dinner last night you need to talk about
what's going on in your relationship
what movie you watched you need that
sense of something to draw on or else
you are going to when you're writing a
story with characters your your mind
will resort to the stereotypical unless
you can use a bit of experiential
something from the room and it usually
comes from the room it comes from people
in the
room we all accept that there are
trade-offs to Virtual Gatherings but are
they bad for creativity how does virtual
video affect collaboration how do we
decide what we do on zoom and when it's
better to come to the
office I'm Kevin Co senior editor at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business
today we speak with Jonathan lava the
king philanthropy's professor of
marketing at Stanford Graduate School of
Business and we'll talk about a paper
Professor lvav co-wrote with Melanie
Brooks now a professor at Colombia
asking about the effects of
communicating via video on creative idea
[Music]
generation we wanted to contrast is
working face to face versus working over
video and the reason that came about was
in part because of a conversation that
I'd had with a friend of mine who's a
notable a noted Silicon Valley CEO who
always said to me that in order for
product development to happen your
engineers have to be
collocated and I believe one of the
exercises you had the study participants
do was think of uses for bubble wrap
right now that that seems like a fun
exercise I me I would like to be a part
of that sort of meeting yeah so what did
you find so what you're referring to is
what's called in the creativity
literature the alternative uses task
what you do essentially is you give
people
an object and you say what are what are
all the different ways in which you
could use that object okay in this case
it was bubble wrap and then your
dependent variable is the number of uses
people come up with right so if I came
up with 10 different uses and you came
up with five different uses and I
generated more ideas than you generated
so basically what we did in the study is
we contrasted the number of ideas and
the type of ideas we can talk about that
a little bit later both the number and
the type of ideas the that pairs of
participants generated whether they were
in person or if they worked over zoom
and what was the result drum roll can we
have it and so the result was that pairs
that worked face to face generated more
ideas about 15 to 20% more ideas than
pairs of people that worked on zoom and
everybody got the same amount of time to
work and the same incentive to work but
people that worked face to face
generated more ideas but even more
interesting than that was that if we
analyze we were able to analyze the
ideas that people generated the pairs of
people generated and we could analyze
those ideas not just for the number of
ideas but for the type of ideas and how
connected those ideas are to each other
and so imagine um I I tell you um Kevin
I want you to give me as many
alternative uses for a frisbee you can
so you can say
frisbee paint
pallet
plate SLP
okay those are very unrelated Concepts
that all could be alternative uses for a
frisbee contrast that with frisbee plate
coaster tray those are all things that
are related to serving food so that's a
much narrower set of ideas and so the
interesting thing was that not only did
people who worked on Zoom generate fewer
ideas but their ideas tended to be more
clustered together than the people that
worked face to face so it's almost like
you get a double penalty one penalty is
in the number of ideas and what you want
in let's say a new product development
process is to generate as many
possibilities to select from in the idea
generation phase of the new product
development process and you want those
ideas to be as different from each other
as possible because then that also
allows you to connect things that are
otherwise unconnected and create
something that's more novel and so
working on Zoom was a double penalty
fewer ideas and a narrower set of ideas
MH so those of us who've been in
Creative meetings on zoom and that's a
lot of
people this does seem sort of intuitive
maybe to what our experience is but why
do you think that difference exists what
sort of objectively is different about
it so first of all I don't know that
it's intuitive so I I've had that
response from people so I remember when
I I presented this in a class of
Executives and I said what do you think
would happen if I ran this experiment
and they said oh people work working
face to face would generate more ideas
and I asked them why and they said well
because you would you would just gen
generate more because you're working
face to face so you you can't have the
explanation be the be the experimental
treatment and so on the face of it if
the information exchange is the
same in theory there shouldn't be a
difference and after we published the
paper and had the result went out and
was picked up by the press and so on and
so forth we had a lot of people who
really fought us tooth and nail to tell
us how we were wrong they didn't
necessarily present any evidence that we
were wrong but they just kept telling us
that how our experiments were terrible
they didn't point to particular factor
in the experiment but just that they
were terrible and that's when you start
getting a sense that people here have
more religious belief around this
question than data and so let's think
about having a conversation so right now
we're sitting in this um studio in the
studio there's all kinds of stuff right
so there's a poster on the wall there's
the door there's the Stanford Business
backdrop there's all kinds of wires
micros microphones and so on and so
forth if I look away for a moment at
something else right I'm still in this
conversation right you know that I'm
still here because our shared
environment is this entire room okay but
think about what it means to work over
video or on Zoom or whatever other
platform you're using now our shared
environment is this narrow monitor right
typical laptop monitor sizes 13 in
everything else is outside of that
shared envir M so the way to think about
it a little bit is like um the iPhone
portrait mode right so in the iPhone
portrait mode you you you you focus on
one object and everything else gets
pixelated that's a little bit like what
sort of Zoom requires of you so in order
to remain in the conversation I have to
remain in the shared environment in
order to remain in the shared
environment I basically have to put
blinders on it's almost like narrowing
your gaze now there's uh research that
shows that people's
physical experience influences their are
cognitive style so if you think about it
I have to be super narrow and super
focused that's going to translate into
cognitive style that's also narrower and
more focused and so in in a creative
idea generation task which is you what
you want to be is to think expansively
right I want to sort of generate ideas
lots of ideas unrelated to each other if
you will like a big gigantic oak tree of
ideas now I have a physical experience
that's narrowing me down and instead of
making an oak I make a Cyprus
and so what we found is pretty strong
relationship between people's physical
experience and we measured that by
actually filming them and seeing where
their eyes went and their creative
output and so that's the thing about
Zoom that sort of makes it particularly
unique is that it's not just an
experience of talking to each other but
it's actually a phys where the physical
experience of consuming information is
different and for some tasks like
creative idea generation that can
potentially have an import influence so
if I'm a manager in an organization and
I'm trying to
evaluate when Zoom is okay and when Zoom
is not okay or whether in person is much
better than Zoom we know that creativity
based on your research those should be
in person how do we differentiate other
things that we might do on zoom and how
would that relate to maybe making an an
overall evaluation on when people should
be at work and when they can be remote
yeah so
there was another result that we found
in our experiments that was weaker than
the creativity results but still there
which is that in addition to generating
ideas the pairs of participants had to
select which idea they thought was the
best all of their ideas were then
submitted to an external jury that
judged it on novelty and
usability right so if we think about a
Innovative product it's both novel and
usable right and so we could me measure
how accurate each pair's decisions were
with respect to this external standard
so let's suppose we generated 10 ideas
and our best idea was rated a six and
the idea that we submitted was in fact
rated a six then we made a quote unquote
perfect decision and we submitted the
idea that was rated a five then we would
have scored a minus one right that's the
size of our error so you can have a
small error you can have a big error and
so what we found is that actually the
groups working on Zoom did a little bit
better at the decision-making task than
at the creative idea generation task and
if you think about the psychological
requirements of the decision-making task
it makes some sense because to make a
decision I have to narrow down on
something I have to be analytical I have
to be focused it's the exact opposite of
the expansive thinking that's required
in creative idea generation and so that
sort of gave us the hint that the story
here isn't Zoom versus Zoom is bad or
Zoom is good is that different
modalities are matched to different task
requirements and so that's a roundabout
way to get an answer to your question
which is look what matters isn't are you
working at home are you working hybrid
are you working in the office is what
are the psychological requirements of
the task and so if it relates to
expansive thinking you want to be in an
environment that doesn't Force you force
this kind of cognitive narrowness and if
you have to be analytical and so and
focus and that cognitive narrowness
actually might help you our colleague
Nick Bloom who studied this for a very
long time and and and the econ
department has a pretty famous paper
that says shows that call center workers
I believe it was in a travel agency in
China were 12% more productive when they
worked from home than when they worked
at the call center and so the conclusion
from that for many years was yeah you're
more productive when you work from home
but it turns out if you think about what
that task is it's not that you're at
home that makes it that made you more
productive is that the task requirements
match the kind of environment that you
have at home what do I mean by that if
I'm a customer service agent right and
sitting in a call center I have to do
two tasks actually the first one is to
listen to the customer and the second
one is I have to suppress all the noise
that's around me maybe there's not a ton
of noise but there's some noise I got to
suppress that so now that's going to
naturally hurt how productive I can be
because my attention is split now
imagine I I go work at home at home I
can actually control the volume of the
environment around me usually I'm
working in quiet right and because I'm
working in quiet I don't have to
suppress these other noises and that
allows me to give more attention to the
customer so it's really about what does
the task require and how the
requirements of the task match the
modality of the work environment and so
that's what managers have to do they
have to ask themselves okay what really
requires us to be in the office because
it does require expansive thinking
because psychological distance does
matter for that kind kind of stuff what
could be done better at home like
something like that where actually being
in the office is could be a distraction
rather than an aid and what type of
things does it not matter and then I can
let the employee really decide whatever
it is they prefer right so I don't know
if I'm doing my taxes it might not
matter right where I am as long as I can
handle some distraction while doing my
taxes right
right your list listening to if then a
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business we'll continue our conversation
after the
[Music]
break so we're starting to see companies
and tech companies in particular
starting to try to pull people back in
in some cases for a third day for
example
yeah what is there any evidence or are
you aware of conversations policies that
are happening in these organizations
about what the criteria is for that or
is it more about they think for some
reason philosophically that it's better
to have people in the office than not I
don't know of any systematic study that
looks at various categories of task
requirements in the workplace and
matches them to workplace modality so
right now all we're seeing is basically
a tension between employers that want to
have control over the production
function and employees who would prefer
to avoid commutes and wearing that are
perfectly happy to more happy to work in
pajamas than they are to like get
dressed in in work clothes and they
would rather be able to go to the gym at
11:00 in the morning as opposed to at
600 p.m. after they leave work right and
you put your finger on what that tension
is in one case it's kind of lifestyle
and in the other case it's production
and religious belief if that's the case
so assuming that organizations want
Happy employees they want to retain them
and maybe in all cases they don't but
let's assume for a moment that they
do what are some ways they can convince
people to come into the office rather
than just sort of stating three times a
week for reasons that may be nebulous
yeah so so there's a little bit of an
underlying assumtion of what you're
saying is that what I want is I want to
keep all the employees that I have
because I'm motivated to retain my
employees and I think that's only a
partial yes I think that what we're
going to find is that there's some
employees that
maybe they just don't fit the workplace
modality like if I'm a fully remote
company it requires a certain type of
employee and if I'm a kind of company
that is wants to have people mostly in
the office then you have to have people
who are willing to do that and who
actually prefer or who embrace it and so
I think that you you can imagine there
over the next couple of years being like
reshuffling depending on people's
preferred work Styles now there's no
doubt that it's more convenient for me
to stay at home than it is for me to be
in the office so I think that what
employers need to start thinking about
is to ask themselves what's the job that
being at home is doing for people that
they're so rabit about it and I think
that job is convenience it's avoiding
commute it's flexibility
right it's a sense of familiarity and
comfort and safety and so you have to
start thinking as an employer how do I
provide that in alternative ways so
right now typical office open you know a
day starts at 8 or 9 o00 but guess what
else starts at 8 or 9 o00 schools which
means that there's always going to be
more traffic around 8 or 9 o' which
means something that could take me
should take me 15 minutes can take me 45
minutes or an hour in some cases an hour
and a half so maybe we have to start the
work day at 10:30 or at 11: or some kind
of staggered form okay maybe um if we
know that people like the flexibility of
being a little work out go to their
pilates class at 1:00 actually make that
part of the workplace norm and say
explicitly you know we want almost
expect you to go exercise once a day
whenever you want as long as it fits
your work day here's a gym membership
that allows you to go at any number of
gyms in the
area right but the kind of task that you
engage really requires you to be in the
office we want to have a nod towards the
things that made home such a hospit in
such a convenient place for you what
would you advise a manager or a senior
leader who's trying to find that sweet
spot uh between the mix of office and
work and and what should they be
thinking about when their people are
remote I'm going to give you an
unsatisfying answer which is an answer
that's actually going to require you to
answer some questions not you
specifically but the listener and
so the thing that people have to
understand is that all those things that
you learned about how to
lead in a face-to-face environment pre-
pandemic right because everything we're
talking about now is pre and post
pandemic that skill set uh and those
Norms that were developed in the
workplace that culture those forms of
communication those habits that kind of
transfer of knowledge you kind of have
to relearn it and redo it for the remote
in the remote work experience and and
and and what you have to do actually is
you have to engage in in a process that
says okay what were the elements of the
culture that I had that were critical to
me what were the things that we did that
were carriers of those of that culture
and then say okay if I'm in a hybrid
environment or a remote
environment what do I have to do in
order to be able
to create the that same kind of culture
that same kind kind of style or whatever
that same kind of workflow so so if
before like one of the ways we used to
connect was we everybody end up going to
coffee at 9:00 we kind of all converged
for coffee at 9:00 now that we're
working far away we actually have to
deliberately set up an alternative in
March 2020 we moved from working phase
to working from home and we just kept on
doing the same
stuff except now we're talking to each
other through a screen but no but then
there's all these other things that we
did around that were essentially the
scaffold around which work was done that
then kind of fell by the wayside and we
actually have to need to actively
replace those because it's all those
scaffoldings that actually make the work
environment meaningful for people and so
I can tell you like teachers here at
Stanford I remember we essentially one
day I taught face to face and then the
next class I was showing the same slides
and doing the same things online and it
doesn't
work it doesn't work because when you're
online people tend to drift when I'm
face to face I can see when they're on
their phone I can see when they're on
their email cuz I know where their eyes
are going MH right but when I'm working
on Zoom now like nobody's really looking
you in the eye on Zoom because the the
camera is in a different place it's a
different place than the screen so it
always looks like you're not looking at
me even though you might be looking at
me right so we're always
miscommunicating and kind of there's no
way to fix that unless some kind of AI
fixed the Gaze but at some point I
learned that wait if my class is all
about engagement and engagement is
important to me when I was face to face
I could create engagement by walking
towards somebody by a changeing
inflection in My Voice by moving my arms
in a certain way that would make people
understand you know just like a
conductor that wants that that uses his
arms or her arms in order to be able to
kind of really move the orchestra I can
do that face to face on Zoom I can't do
it sometimes you don't even see my hands
so I had to make a transition I said you
know what if if leaning in is such an
important element of my class
environment I'm just going to call call
and I would have entire 80-minute pairs
where I would call
call exclusively there was no hand
raising and what that meant was that
people knew that at any point in time I
can call on them so then they had to
lean in but that was an adjustment I had
to make and I had to make a conscious
change you you can't just default into
it you have to make a conscious change
and so if to to to really manage in this
new environment you have to stop and say
okay what are the things I care about
okay now how do I um enact those in this
remote situation because what you used
to do it doesn't work right it's not the
same stuff there's not the same features
of the environment right so let's pivot
just a little bit you've done a lot of
research on consumer Behavior how to
influence people decisionmaking
sure are there any parallels from that
research to what we're talking about now
with respect to managing a team and
incentivizing or getting them to sort of
make decisions or think about something
differently how
does creating a situation where they are
evaluating this thing as compared to
that thing as an
option what's the process that they are
engaged in there in decision making and
how can that be manipulated if that's
the right word or changed or how can you
lead them to a decision that you want
them to make ah so so what you're
describing is something that in
literature is called Choice architecture
and the idea in Choice Arch Ure is that
you think about it broadly this way you
have two choices suppose you want to get
someone to engage in a certain Behavior
you can either try to convince them to
engage in that behavior and then hope
that when the decision Point comes they
choose the option that's congruent with
the thing you tried to convince them to
do okay so that's call that the
persuasion approach the other approach
the approach of choice architecture says
wait if I designed a decision
environment taken into account people's
psychological Tendencies and the way way
the mind works then I can influence
people's Decisions by virtue of the
situation right I don't have to
sometimes I tell my students that I
don't have to admonish them to do
something I put them in a situation
where the decision I want them to make
that's better along some Dimension that
I'm trying to maximize is is is a
natural outcome of the psychological
process and I do that and and it's not
that I'm incentivizing to do one thing
versus do another but I'm creating a
situation where they're more likely to
do one thing than another one of the one
of the philosophers of business that I
love quoting in my class is is the
rapper Snoop Dog and Snoop Dog says that
it's too easy for kids to join gangs and
do drugs we should make it easy uh to do
football in academics and he's
absolutely right right he's a really
good he has the um intuition for to
Choice architecture make easy the
decision that you want people to make
and then they're more likely to make it
if I tell people that it's really
important to recycle and but to recycle
they got to go to their garage to throw
something out they're not going to do it
but then when garbage can manufacturer
started doubling up the cans right so
now you have a can for trash and a can
for recycling now all of a sudden people
recycle why because you've made it easy
that's that's the idea in that sort of
body of research so you talked about and
you use Snoop Dog yeah as an example of
make the decision easy yeah how do you
make the decision easy for people to
come back to
work I think if you I think that if you
make work be a place of Greater meaning
for people above and beyond the actual
work
itself people search for meaning in
their lives they search for connection
they search for relationships they
search for opportunities to express
their identity they search for
opportunities to express their
individuality they search opportunities
to show off they search for
opportunities to relate right as you
want work to be the place that they
naturally think about as the outlet for
all those desires right and so you have
to build the work environment with those
Desires in mind right and so then you
become easier then you also become
easier on some issues like
conveniences right if it's if it if my
commute to work is short as opposed to
long now all of a sudden but it's easier
I've lowered the cost um of going to
work if work provides me things that I
can get at home right so we talked um
earlier about gym memberships right so
if if if work gives me that or has a gym
in the office now all of a sudden I
don't have to interrupt I don't have to
leave the place where I'm at in order to
be able to get a workout in assuming
that's my value the the time the ability
and the time to exercise then that makes
it easier I think tech companies
did that to some extent with food for a
long time the food experience at a lot
of these companies was extraordinarily
Central right so it makes it easy to
sort of that solves my lunch problem or
my dinner problem or my breakfast
problem right so those are ways those
are ways to make the office decision an
easier decision yeah yeah you talked
about working from home in your pajamas
I showed up once in a workout pants cuz
I went to exercise and forgot to bring
something else and my boss said nobody
cares yeah and by way what you want
and that's great right so now he allowed
you or she I don't know to express
yourself in the way you want and so now
he's made being you easy so you're you
Visa other people when you're at home by
yourself there's no other people right
and so at least the office now is kind
of an easy way to be able to express
yourself what interested you in this
kind of research in the first place why
why are are you studying the things
you're studying and why did you choose
the career you chose so it's a funny
story and it goes back to my mother but
not my mother as in my mother inspired
me to do it
but I called my mother when I was a
junior in college considering what I was
going to take in the spring semester and
I was going to take five classes and I
had chosen four and she called and I
called her and I talked to her and she
says well what classes are you taking
next term and I said well I'm taking
camber one two 3 4 and the fifth one I'm
not sure if to take this one or this
other class and I don't remember I don't
honestly don't remember which two
classes I was considering but one of
them was was a class called the
psychology of decision- making and
judgment it was Psy 321 wws 312 that was
the code and she said who's teaching
that and I said a guy named D Conan she
goes Daniel Conan oh you should take
that class he's really famous so my
mother is a okay you're G to tell me why
she knew that so my mother's a neuros
psychologist and she said yeah he's
really famous and I was like so what do
you do I was like sure I'll do whatever
my mother tells me right and so I took
that class literally cuz my mom said you
should take that class that guy is
really famous and so I took that class
and I just loved it it was the first I
believe yeah it was the second year that
the conoman taught at
Princeton what's the next question you
want to have answered what's the next
thing you want to study I don't know but
I think
listen I'm going to the obvious thing is
listen the next great revolution of our
time is artificial
intelligence and I think that once we
get past this like oh my god wow look
what Chachi PT just wrote for me phase
we're going to have to start
understanding the psychological
interface between the human being and
the Machine and so we talk a lot about
co-piloting and cop piloting can mean a
lot of different things that can affect
us psychologically in a lot of different
ways and by the way when I'm in a
cockpit of a 737 there's two pilots
right there's a captain and a first
officer is the machine going to be the
first officer or is it going to be the
captain right and how does that change
how does that and when and kind of how
does that change things so that's
clearly one place another place that we
really want to keep pushing is hybrid
work is here to stay and remote
Communications are here to stay and want
to kind of dig in further into that so
we're studying a bit now about sort of
people's emotional responses to each
other face to face versus on video and
eventually what I want to really do I
want to study networking cuz a lot of
what we do at work is Network MH and if
the type of information that we exchange
differs when we're face to face versus
over video then it can change the type
of relationships that we build and so
the question is how does that change
those relationships how does that change
the information that's exchanged who
does it affect the most and in what way
so I think those are the directions that
I'm going to go in but we'll see I'll
ask Chach
PT or your mother or my mother yeah who
by the way at 79 soon to be 80 still
works for full-time as a
neuropsychologist yeah thanks Jonathan
pleasure if then is produced by Jesse
Baker and Eric nuum of magnificent noise
for Stanford Graduate School of Business
our show is produced by Jim KGAN and
Julian Nat mixing and sound design by
Kristen Müller from Stanford GSB Jenny
Luna soral husbands Den Holtz and
Elizabeth wiic Stern if you enjoyed this
conversation we'd appreciate you sharing
this with others who might be interested
and hope you'll try some of the other
episodes in this series for more on our
professors and their research or to
discover more podcasts coming out of
Stanford GSB visit our website at
Stanford
gb.edu find more on our YouTube channel
you can follow us on social media at
stanford. GSB I'm Kevin
Co